et bien bonjour comment allez vous nous
ça va extrêmement bien je suis avec mon
collègue maxence oui la vidéo les a mais
aujourd'hui il est temps enfin ça fait
un mois qu'on se retient de mater ce qui
se passe sur le hashtag tourner la page
c'était dur de ne pas regarder de pas ce
sport j'avais trop envie de voir
s'allonger
j'en ai gardé de trop au début tu sais
non mais on va vous spoil cinq idées du
livre en a 36 au total etc les cinq
seule idée ou en fait vous devez être
créatif ce serait trop facile de vous
juger si on se juger pas nous-mêmes de
on à nous-mêmes remplissait pas je
pensais pas ce que l'autre a fait et on
va découvrir ça va être amusant
premières pages sur lequel il faut
dessiner il s'agit d'une bande dessinée
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui rentre
dans un bar qui ouvre sa chemise dans
cette voie une fille est choqué mais il
manque la dernière case de la bd dans
mon qu'on sait pas ce qu'ils avaient
sous la chemise
il faut qu'on dessine sa le premier
alors que ça c'est mes tétons moi c'est
pas mal c'est quand même très la très
bien au fait elle a agit bien là et
c'est incroyable elle s'est plus
concentré sur la tête du mc kelle sur la
plage finale est clair la deuxième
dessin ok là pour le coup on voit les
tétons c'est pas mal finalement sur la
chute c'est qu'en fait c'est un homme
qui est en fait une paire de seins voilà
c'est dit dès maintenant - 18 et ne
rapportera pas d'argent pas mal pas mal
de très jolis dessins ça ce ça se donne
les moyens
c'est pas mal elle fait à jack est ce
qu'on a c'est là que tu vois que les
cerveaux sont différents
mais en voyant en voyant ça il s'est dit
ah mais c'est sega qui vaille dernier
alors que non mais du coup ça peut être
un indice tous bah ouais c'est juste
attendu suivant il a fait un agent à
tous epson oui je sais c'est pas très
clair mais bon monsieur se classe au bo
classique mais j'ai toujours décider
quoi 0,9 fois qu'il avait une paire de
boom
il ya un sens plus gros clubs comme dans
la vraie vie en fait c'est vrai mon
toujours un sens plus gros lot comme
nous on a une culture est ce que l'eau
c'est vrai voilà vous finirez moins bête
à la fin de cette vidéo suivant aux ong
je suis aussi fan de squeeze avec le
feutre tout le tracé parfait 20 mai et a
pris les mecs en moi moi cette tâche à
côté
enfin même temps je suis vraiment pas
dessiner mais je suis tiré un descendant
pas mal de l'actualité en tout cas le
dessin tu vois faire les bras qui vont
dans les manches comme ça c'est
exactement ce que j'ai pas réussi à
faire sur le mien a juste devant
hollande oui mais avec un goût plus en
plus ça marche à mal payés
c'est peut-être qu'il s'est fait
galfingue j'aime ça non je lui fais y
soient à bas mais qd je me sens bizarre
de ce fait la banque non d'un canular
non oui à regarder un vaccin c'est à
nous de montrer ce que nous avons fait
sur cette page
on commence par qui enfin bien fait
saison 1 2 3 a bien failli ciseaux ok
c'était temps qui courent ça que je
commence tu es prêt
haha mais d'agir monde et c'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai tapé gros vente sur
google alors du coup c'est un monsieur à
côté de sa maison et qui bonjour a tous
moi c'est anthony même bien super on
passe à une planche ou brutus qui est un
personnage du livre s'est fait recaler
de d'un salon de tatouage et du coup ça
ne lui dessiner des tatouages sur les
bras le corps voilà comme vous voulez
c'est parti or trop atteinte romo et la
personne n'est quand même en manque
d'inspiration
j'en rajoute au spoil ce qui va se
passer après tu as réussi à faire des
tribunes jeu du hc patrie balcer maori
attention à excuser moi ou la [ __ ]
mais c'est fou le lol sur la tête il est
là il est parce qu il est déjà sûr dès
sa deuxième hausse mignot troisième avec
c'est drôle ça c'est le crabe
ça c'est la chouette qui est là c'est
une super bonne idée c'est très bonne
idée souvent assez minime [ __ ] mais
c'est dur parce qu'on sent par contre
mais la page est enfin c'est ce format
donc c'est pas hyper grands noms plus
quoi en fait bien jouer brutus a
désormais tous les otages qu'ils
voulaient si la vie de la terre relève
toi car ce quart de ligue 1 les gones
cannes johnny en fait ces choix que
c'est un mix de tout les pires tatouage
arrête c'est la ligne à laquelle elle
dauphin rien je suis désolé à tous les
gens qui on s'était tous on est vraiment
déçu mais la france juge pas approcher
les godes cân gio à deux ou trois sont
aux petits dessins d'aujourd'hui avec ce
moteur tourner la page ben franchement
on pourrait croire que c'est le bordel
gens mais enfin bon c'est normal en fait
t'as vraiment pas et en plus elle allait
lui acheter des chevaux tatouage cheveux
pour les choses c'est une super idée tu
nous dis comprend les potes ça j'en fais
des chansons voilà machin j'essaie de
cacher un peu le message que je deviens
shop et toi t'en parle comme ça
publiquement
c'est à nous alors on a déjà vu l'idée
là mais bien sûr je n'ai pas oublié
petit carpediem et je me suis permis de
le stylisé aussi au niveau de la tête à
la à nouveau on retrouve là la maison
d'anthony on a vu tout cela n'atteint
tribal je suis une femme j'ai aucune
idée de comment savoir si un tribal
d'accord c'est le tribal king ce qu'il
veut que tout le monde bouge ses fesses
que les femmes ont mis leurs complexes
et a vu je me suis franchement la tête
est incroyable ben puisqu'on en est à
moi je ferais mais l'idée torello dirait
que le mec du coup s'est tatoué des
contrefaçons tu sais ça allait bien elle
est très sale mais les biens page
suivante c'est tout simplement un mec en
chaussettes tongs sauf que il est pas
content de ses chaussettes il veut caser
des motifs et c'est à nous de dessiner
les motifs en light a créé un logo des
chaussettes tort de lâche je pense qu'il
a fait une proposition là ok il veut que
tu lances une main gauche chaussettes
ok on arrive alors à moi qui adore les
chaussettes et en valais c'est vrai ça
va prend mes t-shirts ses deux tantes à
moi je crois ce qui les a je pense que
les acheter et les amis devant lui il a
free il vivait là ils apprécient for
life as we aujourd'hui j'ai un gros mois
je celle-là ça te plait mélanie tu
m'écris whaou
le petit chat fly a jamais eu un début
de coloriage puis là l'envié partie mais
bon alors il est la même idée que moi il
est apte à gérer
il a fait des logos ou au quai où je
faisais ces matches on a même cédé je
solde cette chaussette natsu trop stylé
mais je le veux alors la vérité c'est
que je voulais en faire un motif répété
que l'on a vu en fait la vérité way le
dernier ont compris tu te moques de
monchy moyen d'assouvir un dessin
d'enfant alors - écoute leblond ça
m'allait pas c'est tout repeindre en
noir
doré est elle au jdd claquettes ou
rajouter des petites mains voilà il ya
une claquette poivre blanc
la quête des péages hésité à faire là
exactement pareil battus à coiffer way
quatrième idée un grand méchant menace
de détruire la planète il faut lui
dessiner son visage auj
ricky martin j m moi non pas mal sûr
manger à il a fait froid mais de
méchants et pas mal eh bien oui j'aime
pas trop dans un angle assez colonel
c'est que le cnca j'aime bien ce mot je
vois tu vois vraiment je vois le truc je
vois pas du tout d'où ça vient dit mon
commentaire il a pas trop de plaisir
pas mal c'est un méchant youtube on et
mogi tout à fait d'accord c'est un
méchant
[ __ ] qu'est coude alors moi ce qui est
intéressant c'est surtout les
commentaires et à l'air nul c'est
l'hiver il est bien et qui demande quand
même s'il avait il relevé
ça a l'air tellement péter pas sûr de
lui suivant à ces jeux sans le pastel
pastel syndrome en effet dégueu mais ça
fait genre oltra man c'est le travail ça
héros du japon mais en face il a écrit
en [ __ ] [ __ ] backs il est temps de
montrer nos échanges tu as fait de la
merde les mecs c'est juste un clic droit
à paris n'était pas mon ordi aujourd'hui
mais c'est vraiment drôle sur envahi
faire pareil du coup je contente d'avoir
fait ce nom là même la grande boucle -
nec gérer moi j'ai fait un truc hyper
original qu'on n'a pas vu dans son
enfant non d'accord on a tous un peu de
succès face à ça avec un oui mais c'est
quoi la peine se bouffe mais c'est une
bouche car oui tu connais pas la merde
j'ai vraiment fait de bowling d'élèves
de 5e et des brutus a perdu ses
vêtements le ovi faut le rhabiller à
l'aide de ce que tu peux trouver autour
de toi tu va découper coller des trucs
dessus ou juste dessiné alors qu'est-ce
que j'en fais chez les bonnes vieilles
passé
la curie faussement c'est fou telle
maladie quand tu ris en délaissant la
suivent en hausse et pas mal quand il
s'est fait chier m'a pas fait exprès
jeune henry c'est le cas ça comme excuse
c'était pas voir du vrai hockey
franchement il a géré il a fait un truc
trop bien je suis hyper jaloux il a
découpé pile pour que ça laisse les
mains et ou [ __ ] bien joué au haut
non mais [ __ ] j'ai exagéré il a pris
une page du livre
oui il est vrai et ça c'est du sopalin
c'est très bien trouvé sa découverte
c'est pas mal c'est à nous c nous cèdent
à gtc colère de voir ce que j'en appelle
aux tu te fais chier ce style de mec là
je découpais jupe d'une bande dessinée
bien là j'ai découpé un morceau de
chemise et là j'ai découpé pareil un
truc d'une bande dessinée le way le
casque est tout le temps ce style et en
bois
merci mais je suis fier de toi lézatois
alors moi dis toi brutus ça m'a saoulé
je voulu changer de personnage donc je
suis parti sur lucas qui porte un petit
débardeur kelvin kleenex avec un sarouel
en musclant mouchoir usagé je sors d'un
petit rhume et du coup aussi bas autant
pas gaspiller mes petits mots soit le
choix usagers effet un petit sarouel
avec un petit jeu de mot sur le kelvin
kleenex max bouge pas je te remettre le
trophée de la meilleure page de tourner
la page
mon père me disait tu suis obligé mais
qu'est ce que vous faites trop et
pourtant j'ai pas mis par longtemps à le
faire enfin je ne m'a pas pris beaucoup
de temps après c'était une pudeur c'est
trop vite et encore merci je vous avais
pas démérité vous non plus maxence tiens
j'ai recycler un trophée vous savez j'ai
barré le cousinage au merci à toi même
tu barras parce que j'ai mis pour nathan
que cette conférence
c'est infernal et orleans a mis sa
fantaisie aux maillots sera plus égale
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude mais que ça fait plaisir
géant d hyper cool j'ai enfin vu ce que
les gens créent avec le livre créatif on
a vraiment kiffé on était étonnés mais
très positivement aux manches mais je
suis pas un personnage ça mais non la
vérité c'est que maxence qu il est ému
est tous contents il est y prend une
voix très touchante et moi non c'est en
quelqu'un est toujours géré besoin qu'il
est faux mais c'est juste sur un court
ça et j'ai horreur de qu'on croit qu'on
ne crois pas qu'on met sentiments sont
vraiment vrai et franchement vous allez
gérer c'est trop bien est acheté à
tourner la page
vraiment je vous aime hashtag sur la
page mais que ça faisait longtemps que
j'attendais de voir ce que ce qu'ils
avaient fait que je suis trop content je
pense que maxence du grand bravo aux
étés père créatif merci à vous doit
participer les prochains cachette le
livret n'hésitez pas à partager ces
pages là sur les réseaux hashtag tourne
la page on regardera ce qui se fait ça
nous fait trop kiffé mais merci je suis
trop tout à fait cette vidéo comptons
alethia ok bah moi j'ai mon trophée donc
je compte
[Musique]
ça